- Welcome and hello to
everyone who's coming in.
Give it a minute as people get connected,
get their audio going.
Thank you all for coming, I'm Paul North.
For those of you who've been at this,
you'll know that this is a series
at the Whitney Humanity Center
called the Value of Marx's "Capital".
They're the Franke lectures
In the Humanities and
they are made possible
by the generosity of
Richard and Barbara Franke.
The lectures are intended
to present important topics
in the humanities to a
wide and general audience,
and we usually have had it.
So I appreciate everyone
who's been sticking with us
and who's come back.
I'll thank again Alice Kaplan,
the director of the
Whitney Humanity Center.
Sandra Malan-Bowles and
Leana Hirschfeld-Kroen
for organizing and Audrey
Leak for checking us out.
Those of you who've been
here know that the workshop
will run with a presentation
first and then questions.
I'm gonna ask you to hold your questions
and you can put them in the
chat once we get to the end,
that just keeps us from
losing them up the chat.
Once you do that, we'll go
through them in the order
that they get in there.
And we'll open up your mics
so that you can ask your questions.
If you don't want to ask the question
and you'd like me to just
note that in the chat.
I start usually with a quote
from the author and scholar,
who's visiting us.
This is a quote from chapter
seven of Marx's "Inferno."
This is a arousing passage
that gets my Republican mind going.
Quote, "The precise
institutional arrangements
"that will best suit any
particular group of free
"and associated laborers will necessarily
"have to take into account
the particularities
"of their situation.
"Their common resources, their characters,
"and histories and interrelations.
"The people best placed to
know those particularities
"will be those free and
associated laborers themselves.
"Anyone who presumes to say from afar,
"how they ought to manage
their common affairs
"might rightly expect to be told
"to mind their own business.
"The solutions to each
associations problems
"will have to emerge out of the context
"of the problems themselves
"and the institutions of
freely associated people
"are their own affair,
"provided that no one is dominated."
This is a really exciting
passage from Marx's "Inferno."
I'm gonna turn over the
mic to my colleague,
Paul Reitter, who will introduce our speaker.
- Thanks Paul and thanks
everyone for being here tonight.
And thanks also to Will
Clare Roberts for being here.
Will it's a real pleasure to introduce you
and to be able to interact
with you over Zoom.
Will is as is an associate
professor of Political Science
at McGill university.
And he is a person of
broad ranging interests.
He's worked on such topics
as BDS and political theory
but his main work to date
is the book Marx's "Inferno"
which I imagine many of you know.
It was very widely
reviewed when it came out.
It was reviewed in Jacobin by
none other than David Harvey.
It was re reviewed also in the nation
in a number of academic journals.
And it was the winter
also of the Isaac and Tamara Deutscher
Memorial Prize in 2017.
The book makes a number of bold arguments,
one having to do with Marx's
use of Dante's "Inferno",
hence the title as a kind
of structuring template
in the book.
Another having to do with
the idea that "Capital"
offers a political theory.
And sometimes in some of the reviews,
you can see that these are
treated as separate undertakings
in one book.
When in fact at least in my reading
they're intimately related,
connected by among other things,
Wills interest in the language of capital
and how the language of
capital relates to the language
of Marx's context.
And that's aspect of the book,
I find very exciting and
have learned a lot from it.
Will, let me just add and
closing this introduction
is also an incredibly generous colleague
who has been sharing
his intimate knowledge
of the French edition of
"Capital" with us Paul and me
as we pursue this edition project.
And we're very grateful to him for that
and glad that he's part
of the project as well.
And so, yeah, please join me
in welcoming Will Clare Roberts
to our series here as Paul
likes to say at this point
that would be thunderous
applause, but it's Zoom.
So Will, you can just jump in.
- Thank you Paul, for
that warm introduction.
Thanks to both of you
Pauls for this opportunity
to speak both with the seminar students
and sort of thanks to the Via
Negativa of modern catastrophe
and the technology by
which we cope with it,
to this much wider audience.
And beyond the specific gratitude
that I feel for this opportunity,
I also do feel a much
deeper debt to Paul and Paul
because they are undertaking this,
which is I think a true service
to the scholarly community
bringing out a new translation,
new edition of capital.
The first translation into
English in nearly 50 years,
and it's sorely needed.
I'm gonna have the pleasure of teaching
the manuscript translation in
a seminar of my own at McGill,
beginning in January.
And I'm very excited and
grateful to be able to do so
as all (indistinct) joined us.
It's important to read and
reread "Capital" to the word
and from beginning to end.
And that brings me to the
substance of my comments
for the evening from beginning to end.
I'm gonna start with a
moment of disagreement
or of difference at least.
Something that divides me
from some of the illustrious
colleagues who have
already spoken with you
so far this term.
For many of them, as for
Michael Heinrich, for example
this is a quote from Michael.
"Marx's legacy is not a finished work
"but rather a research program."
And my perspective is not
contradictory, but is different.
I certainly do not want to
deny that capital represents
an open and ongoing research program.
It certainly does.
However, I also think that
it is important to treat
volume one which was published
by Marx, three times in 1867
again in 1872 in a revised edition
and finally in the French
translation of 1872 dates and 75.
I think it's important
to treat it as a book.
So what's a book?
As I teach platonic
dialogues all the time.
And so I know from Socrates
that what is questions
are very, very hard to answer.
But I do think we can agree that books
have certain characteristics.
Books have a beginning and an end.
They have structure, they have shape.
There's something
finished, completed, done.
And now it's sent off into
the public, it's published.
And when it's published,
it exists then as a standalone object.
Something to be encountered
and read as it is
in whatever context it happens to land.
Shortly before Ben Foulkes
published his translation
of volume one, French
theory and part in reaction
against technocrats of
the right and left in part
trying to put an affirmative
face on the out of control
processes of power and
revolt that swept them along,
declared the death of the author.
Unfortunately, I think what we've ended
up with instead might be
the death of the book.
Take for instance the really gruesome
children's author JK Rowling.
When she wishes to indicate
that one of her major characters
in her major works is in fact, a gay man.
She did not do anything
so crass or basic as
included description of
or illusion to that fact in her books.
Rather, she just went on writing her books
however she pleased and
merely declared after the fact
and in the media that this
particular character is gay.
Nothing you might read in the books
could possibly tell you this.
Only the authors extramural
declaration makes it so.
And that seems to me to be an author
declaring the sort of the
death of her own book, right?
They are never finished.
The words on the page
are in the final analysis
completely irrelevant
to their interpretation.
Like that case is absurd obviously.
And so is the author, but the history
of Marxism is not as
unfamiliar as I would like
with the raveling school
of textual interpretation.
The key to what Marx's
works, Marx's published words
often mean is sometimes supposed to be
nowhere in his published
works, nowhere in his pamphlets
nowhere in his books,
nowhere in his articles.
No published word is final.
Since an interpreter can
declare what it should mean
on the basis of something else.
One of Marx's letters or notebooks,
something written by
another author completely
oftentimes current political exigency
or look the most recent
economic crisis, et cetera.
I think it's important
therefore to read volume one
as a book because I think
it's important to treat it
as something done.
I think it's important to treat it
as something that can be deciphered
and explained at the level of the word
at the level of word choice,
sentence construction,
concrete references, the
transition from one thought
to the next.
It matters for my purposes that Marx
never finished volumes two or three.
He never tried to publish the Grundrisse
but he published volume one,
three times in two languages.
And those three versions of the
book were finished products.
They have beginnings and ends
and they can be figured out.
And they can be read and interpreted
therefore, I think without any reference,
I'm not saying that this is the only way
that they can be read and interpreted,
but they can be read and
interpreted without any reference
to anything else Marx wrote
because that's what
publishing a book of means.
It means putting something
into the hands of readers
who may know nothing else about you
and trusting that they can
figure out what's going on.
So that's the perspective
that I'm approaching
the book from.
Now, on the other hand, if
you do know me from my book,
if you're familiar with my book,
you might be thinking to yourself,
wait, aren't you the guy who
claims the key to the structure
of volume one is Dante's "Inferno".
And the key to its argument
is Marx's disagreement
with Pruden like, but fair.
But I have a couple of rejoinders.
First, I wanna say something about
what I take to be the political purpose
and rhetoric of "Capital".
And then I wanna turn to its structure
and in particular to
its relation to Science.
And that means in this
case its relationship
to political economy.
So David Harvey gave a
series of lectures last year
at the People's Forum.
And they're all up on YouTube
in which he sort of reprises
his famous lecture, class
lectures of "Reading Capital."
And he starts those lectures off
by talking about the wealth
of illusions and metaphors
and other literary elements in "Capital".
And then he says, basically, well, yes,
there's all of this wonderful
literary stuff in there,
but at the center of the book
is a certain structure of argument.
I think this is a tried and
true approach to reading Marx.
It's shared by analytical philosophers
and radical geographers alike.
And what it assumes is that "Capital"
can be at least analytically separated
into its argumentative
structure on the one hand
and it's literary references on the other.
And I've never really
shared this perspective.
So another reference, so
in the June 17, 1883 issue
of Laba Thai which was the
radical Parisian newspaper
that was edited by Marx's
almost son in law, (indistinct).
There's a little ad for a
radical workers bookstore
and it trumpets its selection
of socialist Republican propaganda.
And it lists alongside
guests catechism socialist.
(foreign language)
It also lists "Le Capital"
by Carl Marx, five ranks.
I think that little ad
is actually a truer key
to understanding capital
than any hermeneutic
that tries to isolate
the propositional content
and structure of Marx's argument
from its literary form and references.
If you say to a crowd,
expropriate the expropriators.
I don't think it makes a lot
of sense to try to separate out
the argumentative structure
from the literary references
in that claim.
In the following sense,
the argument of that claim
is constituted by the
illusions and metaphors
of the statement.
Expropriation is a Roman
legal concept justifying
the seizure of property
by the public authorities
for the common good.
The redoubling of the term implies
not only that we should seize property
and not only that we should
do so for the common good
but that the current proprietors
also sees it from others themselves.
And I think that's the
most interesting part
and that they seized
it for the common good
or at least they thought they were
or they could represent
themselves as having done so
where they could plausibly
justify themselves in this way.
You can explain and
explicate I think all of this
and it absolutely has an
argumentative structure
but the original statement
remains essentially an effort to propagate
a political analysis and course of action.
Which simply does not make any sense
outside of its references to Roman law
and its imperative form of address.
And I think that's true of
capital as well as a whole.
And this is why radical
booksellers would see it as a book
of socialist Republican propaganda, right?
"Reading Capital" as a
book, therefore for me
does not mean treating it
as sort of hermetically
sealed off from the world.
It doesn't mean that it's locked up
in its internal relations.
Rather it means for me
treating it as an intervention
in the world, referring
constantly to other books,
to other texts, to other discourses
and incidentally this is also
why I'm a little more bullish
on the French edition than
say Michael Heinrich is.
So he made a couple of
references to his criticisms
of the French translation
when he was giving his talk
a couple of weeks ago.
I think that a lot of those
reservations hinge on,
claims in Marx's letters
and that I think are there's
no reason to doubt necessarily,
but that Marx really tried
to simplify and popularize
especially the first couple
chapters for the French edition.
And I think that there are reasons to,
because of that, I think that
Heinrich has good reasons
to look also at the second German edition
and at the appendix to
the first German edition.
But I also think that
Marx's persistent efforts
to popularize and simplify "Capital"
that is to give it a form
of expression that's suited
to uptake and propagation
amongst militant proletarians,
the not be thought of at least simply
as like watering down truths
that the proper expression
of which is exacting
precise and a bit esoteric.
So therefore my emphasis on
volume one status as a book
goes hand in hand with my
insistence which I picked up
in at least in part from Terrell Carver
who gave a talk earlier as well.
That this is a political
intervention, right?
That capital is an address
to the workers movement
and an attempt to propagate
socialist republicanism.
So that's the first thing
I sort of wanted to say.
On the other hand, I think the
presumption that as readers
and now I want to talk more
about this relationship
to Science and structure.
I think the presumption that as readers,
that we should try to
separate out Marx's arguments
from its literary trappings.
I think that that's related to
and the impart draws its strength
from another presumption,
a very old one.
That capital is a work of Science
and a critique of ideology.
A recent essay by Frank Ruda
that you may run into
unpacks that presupposition.
I think it's a fun little
essay but it unpacks
that presupposition with
considerable originality
by reading Marx his ideology
critique as an inheritor
of Plato's image of the cave.
And he aligns that with
but then also says it
requires supplementation
by Hegel's "Science of Spirit".
I don't think everyone is so extravagant
in their elaborations on that
theme of ideology critique
but I think Ruda's explorations
are entirely consistent
with a broad swath of Marxist discourse.
And to discuss this swath
of discourse more broadly
I'm going to have to mention Dante.
So one of the claims I make in my book
is that in "Capital" Marx
cast himself as a Virgil
to the proletariat.
By which I mean he guides
the workers through the hell
of political economy but in the
time since I've written that
and having been questioned
many times about
and pushed on my use of Dante,
I've realized that thinking structurally,
it would be more accurate and
precise to say that Virgil
is to Dante's "Inferno"
as politically economy
is to Marx's "Capital".
So in his "Inferno",
basically I think one way
of reading Dante's
"Inferno" is to just say,
Dante is here narrating for us his own
reading Virgil's indeed.
So Dante is lost and confused
in the middle of his life.
He turns to Virgil's
poem and he finds there
a sort of indirect path to
recovering his Christian faith.
And he was able to do this
because Virgil showed
Dante basically the depths
of human depravity.
He showed him human cruelty and stupidity
and Virgil claimed to know
how to navigate those depths.
And there are some things
that I think Virgil claims
and the immediate, or seems
to, lots of its readers
he claims that wickedness
is its own punishment, for example.
That Virgil is its own
reward and that nature
is sufficient unto itself
and therefore, perfect.
These were teachings that Virgil himself
had probably picked up at least in part
from Lucretius whose (indistinct),
Virgil considered to be the
greatest work of human poetry.
So this is the perverse cruelty of Dante.
So where in the his
moral cosmos does Dante
put his teacher Virgil.
His teacher Lucretius
and all the other followers of Epicurus?
Well, he puts them deep
in the bowels of hell.
His "Inferno" could be
subtitled the critique of Virgil
because it shows him learning from
but also going beyond Virgil.
And it shows him subjecting
all of classical antiquity,
all of the classical antiquity
that Virgil epitomizes
to a damning criticism that
this classical antiquity
and Epicureanism in
particular has no faith in
or insight into the sources of the nature
that it claims to understand.
I think that's basically the role
that political economy plays for Marx.
Marx narrates for us in "Capital"
his own reading of this bourgeois Science.
And he asked his readers to follow along
and just as Virgil booth
claims to know the path
through Hades and is yet
condemned to reside in a hill
that he can't fully comprehend.
So also political economy claims
to know how the production
and distribution of wealth works,
but it's also prisoner of a
capitalist mode of production
that it barely fathoms.
And if this is the right way
to think about the relationship
between political economy and capital
and this is for me what's at
stake in "Reading Capital"
as Marx's "Inferno" then I think
several important consequences follow.
First of all, capital is not
I think part of the tradition
of ideology critique.
At least as that tradition
is usually understood.
In fact, I would go even further.
I would say it's not
even part of the history
of critical theory.
If we accept someone like Raymond Geuss',
reconstruction of that
tradition as in the claim
that critical theories aim
at producing enlightenment
that is knowledge of one's true interests
by emancipating agents from ideology.
I don't think that's what
"Capital" is trying to do at all.
Instead I think "Capital" is part
of a much less appreciated tradition
that of political critiques of Science.
Think for Marx state-of-the-art
Social Science,
political economy can show
us the interconnections
of the world we live in.
It can teach us how this
present social order
hangs together, but it
cannot tell us how to create
a new world or how to go about
inhabiting that new world.
So if the guiding question
of ideology critique
is Spinoza's question,
like why do people fight
for their slavery as
if for their salvation?
Then I think the question for the critique
of Science is different.
It's more like something
like what are the forms
of intelligibility of
systems of domination
and how do these forms of intelligibility
function as justifications for resisting
the emancipatory movements
of the dominated?
So Simon Clark I think
has made a related point.
He said something very similar I think.
And Clark wrote that Marx's
critique of political economy
does not create a space for
a Marxist political economy.
Since political economy can
never do more than describe
the alienated forms of social existence.
So I differ from Clark in
not finding much conceptual
or political clarity in
describing social relations
in capitalism as alienated
forms of social existence.
I think it's better to
say that social relations
in capitalism, in so far as
they're mediated by the market
are dominated forms of social existence.
Be in dominated means
something particular.
It means being exposed to a
power that you cannot control,
a power that can interfere in your life
and upset your expectations at any time.
Therefore dominated agents
while they are not forced
to act in any particular
way have strong incentives
to study, anticipate,
avoid and cater to agents
with dominating power.
Because domination by the
market is not domination
by particular identifiable
agents but by anonymous masters,
or buyers and sellers whose
aggregate acts can ruin me.
It's no surprise, I think,
that it is market-based
capitalist societies
that gave rise to the scientific
study of what Hegel called
in "Philosophy of Right,"
the mass relationships and mass movements
in their qualitative and quantitative
determinacy and complexity.
And that's modern Social Sciences.
Statistical Sciences, Political
Economy, Economic Science.
The Science of Political
Economy, according to Hegel
and I think this is right
it produces knowledge.
This is Hegel.
Knowledge of this
shimmering of rationality
within this sphere of need.
And Hegel therefore says that
it calls it a reconciling
element within modern society.
Marx his critique of political
economy is supposed to,
I think undo this reconciliation
by showing that the
intelligibility of movements
and relations of market mediated society
rest on the domination of
the market dependent producer
in general and the wage market dependent
proletariat in particular.
So that's the first sort of big conclusion
that I wanna draw from that.
The second conclusion that I wanna draw.
And in some ways this is obvious.
So I don't really need the architecture
in order to draw this conclusion,
but we'll go there anyway.
I think Marx's his authority
insofar as he has any
does not arise from any experience
of exploitation or domination, right?
Marx is not an exploited worker.
He's not drawing on
experience in order to say,
look I've seen this, I've done this,
this has happened to me.
Rather, any claim to
authority that he has comes
from his claim to know the enemy.
And more than this, I
think we can go beyond that
and say that I think
capital is an attack on any
would be guides and leaders
of the workers movement
who would claim authority
on the basis of experience.
And I think for this reason,
it's no accident that
Marxism opens up onto
the Leninist question, right?
Where does social democratic consciousness
that is the theoretical
leadership of the movement,
where does it come from?
But it opens up onto this question.
I think not quite for the reason
that Koski and Lennon thought.
It doesn't open up onto this question
because Marxism inherits and incorporates
the history of bourgeois Science, right?
It's not that we have
leadership of the movement
because we have all of
this scientific awareness.
On the contrary it's because
Marxism could plausibly
claim to have discovered the
limits of bourgeois Science.
And I think in that vein,
I think there's room
for something like a general
critical Social Science,
one that identifies and studies any
and all forms of domination
on the model of "Capital".
But I think that this could not be
or even contain a critique of ideology.
I don't think that's
what's at stake at all.
So going back to Guess because I think
he's very clear on this.
I think and so Guess claimed
that the very heart of the
critical theory of society
is its criticism of ideology.
Their ideology is what
prevents the agents in society
from correctly perceiving
their true situation
and real interests.
I think this conception
of the task of critique,
I mean on the one hand, I
think it's just kind of,
in the modern world, I
think it's kind of bankrupt.
I don't think ideology is
the barrier to emancipation
but more apropos of our
topic for this evening.
What is more important right now
is that I think it's
foreign to Marx's "Capital".
I don't think that
conception can draw any basis
of authority from "Capital",
which is not and does not contain,
I think, a critique of ideology.
So far from thinking that
the proletariat is inhibited
by ideology from its efforts
at self emancipation.
I think Marx has complete faith.
Not only that human beings
in general could devise
and implement a global
system of governance
that both protects
everyone from domination
and is democratically accountable
but also that this global system
would and could only emerge
from the struggles of the dominated.
I think Marx's faith in
the masses was as close
as he got to Dante's faith in God.
So if we don't share that faith,
if we don't share that confidence then
I don't think we have any
warrant to base our pessimism
in his "Capital".
So that's the end of my prepared remarks.
And then we can take this discussion
wherever people want to go, thank you.
- Well, here's another moment for applause
and a lot of gasps and wow and okay.
Lots of controversial stuff
I think to talk about.
Thank you.
- I think you said that I was
supposed to take something
that people thought about
"Capital" and disagree with it.
So I tried to fit the brief.
- This is where we valuing
"Capital" here as we speak
or whatever you want to call it.
I appreciate it.
So we'll open up the chat for questions.
I want to encourage the students
in the seminar to pose questions.
We recently finished the
book you can call up.
We did that after a lot of work.
So you should at least locate
the expropriation of expropriaters.
And be able to ask some
questions about that.
Maybe I'll start with a question
if you don't mind, Will.
If you can give a little finer distinction
between what Guess and
maybe even certain line
of Frankfurt School readers of
Marx or non-readers of Marx,
inheritors of an idea of Marx,
think of as the enlightenment
of the people burdened
with a dual consciousness
or ideology and what you're talking about,
the kind of knowledge because
it still seems to be knowledge
that the book is giving
to the working class
and one had a teams to
be that it is steering
the mass readership away
from its representation
by metrical Social Science
towards something else.
So I understand that, but is
it still a form of knowledge
and how is that supposed to work?
That you open up this picture,
you take them into hell
and then you move to almost
automatically in that section.
That's something that
the students remarked on
and I think is right.
And it's not as you know, an imperative.
It's kind of a fatal, complete.
The expropriaters are expropriated
as though it happens magically.
It's almost the same
kind of magic that Guess
or Frankfurt School people think happen
when you take ideology away.
At least the way it's presented.
So what is the difference
in the kind of knowledge
and the kind of change
that happens in the mass
from reading this book?
- That's a great question or
complex of questions, I guess.
So I guess what I want to,
I think the classic
place where people locate
or try to locate a theory
of ideology in "Capital"
is in the discussion of fetishism.
And they see in fetishism a
sort of a false consciousness
in which and this has given birth to,
I mean this gets taken in a
million different directions,
but I think it's incredibly
important that Marx
never calls the fetishism
of the commodities
or the fetish character
of the commodities,
he never calls it false or an illusion.
It is in fact, what
you see is what you get
when you see that social relations
are relations amongst things,
that's because that's right.
So to me, I think that
the attempts to locate
something like a false consciousness
that feels our actual social experience
and that closes us off from an awareness
of our true interests.
I mean, I just think
that's an alien problematic
to what Marx is up to in the book
and that on the contrary,
what he wants to do,
yeah, so you asked, what do we know from,
I mean, we know a couple of things.
On the one hand we know what
political economy knows.
In the sense that we know about
the workings of the market.
We know about how the
circulation of commodities
goes through, we know
about and so you get,
to some extent what Marx
is doing in "Capital"
is improving upon the
Ricardian political economy
of his time.
So part of the work
that he's doing is like
really trying to reconstruct
classical political economy
and give the best version
of political economy
that he possibly can.
But then we also know that
what political economy
in some sense, can't know,
which is that the value
in circulation can't possibly
be grounded in the concrete
labors of the workers.
There can't be a a cycle
of justice where everybody
gets back everything
that they have put in.
So what you get is the blind
spot of a political economy
as well which is the blind spot,
both of the domination of
producers by the market
and the blind spot of exploitation
of the workers in particular.
So I mean, you definitely like Marx
wants to teach you something.
Like I don't want to deny that.
You absolutely come out
of this with knowledge
but it's not, I don't
think it is partly about,
it's about knowing what the breakdowns
of bourgeois political economy are,
like where does it fall apart?
Where does it fail?
- Thanks, yeah, it's a big
topic and a lot of questions,
but it's much clearer.
Okay, we're ready to go
to the chat and forgive me
if I missed you up above.
So we'll start.
And if you got missed, you
can repost your question.
I see a question by Tony Zanella.
Can we open up the mic for Tony
if you're willing to read your question?
- [Tony] Sure, can you hear me?
- Yes.
- You see any sort of direct
connections between Republican
elements in Dante and
Marx's republicanism?
So, one example I gave was
like how keto is elevated
to the guardian of the purgatory
instead of being consigned to hell.
So that's it.
- I mean, this is not a question
that I've actually explored.
I don't know.
My feeling about Dante is
that Dante doesn't care
about freedom especially
like Dante cares about faith
and truth and beauty and like freedom
is not a positive value
necessarily for Dante, I think.
I mean, so I I haven't looked at this.
I think what you point out is interesting
the elevation of keto.
That is interesting but of course,
Dante is a hardcore monarchist.
And in fact, you know,
in his book on monarchy,
proposes a global
monarchy, a global empire
that would have a terrestrial
and a spiritual side.
So I'm open to,
I love reading Dante,
and I love thinking about
all of the crazy stuff
that Dante is up to because
Dante is absolutely a,
I mean, he's a canny and very intelligent
political operative as well
as just being a great poet.
But like I said, I haven't
thought more about this.
- Thank you, Tony.
Okay, now we have a question
from Sam, Samore or Samore.
can we open up Sam's mic?
- Hi.
- [Paul] Hi, welcome.
- [William] Hello.
- I got at the end of your talk,
I got a little boxed on the bridge
between on the one hand if
you can't claim authority
for leading the dominated
masses via your experience
is dominated to Marx's his absolute faith
in the dominated in general to
be a force of transformation.
So I was wondering if
you could just clarify
the link there.
- Yeah, fair enough.
It was less of a bridge
than like a hail Mary pass
or something like that.
So I guess what I wanted
to at least gesture
to are a couple different things.
So on the one hand, the
theoretical clarification
that the workers movement needed,
Marx's thought was this
sort of negative theory.
In the sense that it's what the theory
that they need is I mean,
they do need an account.
They do need political economy.
They do need to understand
political economy
but they also need to see, as I said
they need to see the limits
of political economy.
And up to that point,
up to the point of
"Capital" Marx thought that,
only Pruden had really even tried to talk
about political economy
in an intelligent way
or taking it seriously at all.
And all I did was produce a bunch of,
unfortunately very Smithian peons
to the beauty of change of commodities.
So on the one hand
Marx thinks that the
theoretical leadership
that the worker's movement
needs is this clarification
of the stakes of political economy
and a proper sort of
destruction of political economy
as a Science.
On the other hand,
that sets aside the question
of political leadership.
Political leadership may
well come from experience,
but the theoretical clarification
is not going to come
from any sort of experience
of being exploited.
It's not going to come
from any sort of experience
of being cheated in a exchange,
or from having to pay a high interest rate
or something like that.
Like, that doesn't clarify the situation
of the proletariat.
It doesn't clarify how capitalism
works or hangs together.
And it doesn't point to the
limits of the capitalist mode
of production at all.
So that's the thing, I
guess I want to separate out
the sort of theoretical question,
the theoretical leadership
and the political leadership question.
For Marx those are just gonna
be very separate things.
I think that's the upshot.
- Thanks, that's really helpful.
- Great.
- Thanks, yeah, I don't
know how you feel about this
but I feel like there hasn't
been a satisfactory answer
to the question, what Marx
thought the book would do.
There's that story that
(indistinct) likes to quote
which is when the La Commune
was announced, Marx said,
"Well, how could they do that?
"I haven't finished the book yet."
So he obviously,
he had some sense.
This book was gonna do
something almost immediately
and you're approaching that.
That's a really important question.
And myself totally agree
that it's not to expose
a secret only or to blow off the illusion
as though that would be enough.
I want to,
okay, I'm picking through the questions
'cause I wanna get ones that
are that are really related
to the talk first.
Okay, how about we go to Sumanth Gopinath.
Can we open Sumanth's mic?
- [Sumanth] Sure, I wasn't really making,
posing a question, but just saying
that when you were speaking,
I thought of Balibar's argument
in the Philosophy of Marx
that ideology is really
a theory of the state.
It came from an earlier
period of Marx's work
and that fetishism is
a theory of the market
and that these things are not equivalent.
Maybe the question would
be what do you think
of that argument?
How do those things relate?
There's certainly a lot
of ideological bullshit
in the traditional political
economy that can be unpacked
and Marx is very good at skewing that.
And so, I don't know, I go back and forth
on this question myself
but I'd love to hear
your thoughts on that.
- Yeah, I mean, it's a great question.
So, and it's definitely a question.
So that the little Balibar
book was very important
for me at one point.
And I would probably need to go back to it
with fresh eyes now and
see what I think of it now.
I think that general division
of labor between ideology
and fetishism is right,
and I'm pretty skeptical
that you can get much
of a theory of ideology
out of Marx at all,
even in the early Marx.
I mean, you have a few scattered
comments about ideology,
hither and yon, and you
don't really get anything
like an attempt even
to to systematize them
or anything like that.
So my inclination is to say that Balibar
is definitely onto something.
The notion of ideology as the ideas
of the ruling class does accord.
I think with Marx's
earlier sort of concerns
where he was much more into the model
of the French revolution
and just kind of pushing
the French revolution
through to another level
in Germany and thinking that it would,
you just have to keep pushing
the rock further and further.
And in that context, that ideology
seems like a, yeah, something
like a public discourse
of legitimacy and set of
categories for thinking
about politics that emanate
pretty straightforwardly
from the official
mouthpieces of the state.
I mean, I think it's ironic because Marx
was much more of a
hopper mossy and in 1842,
than he was later on.
I mean, Marx spent a long
while trying to basically
bootstrap Germany into
freedom via the creation
of a public sphere.
Just on the back of heroic journalists
who wouldn't be silenced
and that it took him a while
to leave that sort of set of
concerns and strategies behind.
- That's great (indistinct).
Well, I was just going to say
political defeat of the 1848
revolution probably has
something to do with--
- Yes and political defeat
proceeded theoretical defeat.
In the sense that, like, I
mean, the political defeat
in the political defeat
of the Ryan (indistinct)
and the original one,
definitely caused something
of a break in how Marx
thought about politics.
And that's when he just
discovers the proletariat,
that's when he begins to put
his hopes in the excluded
in the dominated rather
than in the enlightened.
But I do think there are
hangovers, theoretical hangovers
of that political defeat
that lasts for much longer
and absolutely the same is
true of the defeated in 1848.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you for your question, we'll go to
a kind of a technical question.
Can we open up Gabby Nair?
Gabby are you willing to read it out?
- Yeah, of course.
Yeah so what do you make of
the claim from Arthur Smith
(indistinct) crowd that Marx
is doing systematic dialectics.
And how do you feel that this relates
to your claims regarding domination?
- Yeah, so I spent a while
as a systematic dialectitian.
Around 2005, I was very into this
and absolutely I think, yeah, basically
I think that entire group
are engaged in a process
of attempting to theoretically reconstruct
the Marx's conception of capitalism.
As a dialectically interrelated whole,
I mean, basically to take,
to save it along the lines
that Hegel's conception
of absolute knowing is to historicize that
and to say that's correct
for the structure of capital as such.
And that's that.
I mean, I feel like there
are too many mediations
between that and the claims
that I'm making to straightforwardly say
what I think the connection is there.
Because in part Marie
and Rutin and Arthur,
like they have a different
problematic than me.
They're treating Marx
as a research program
although more of a
ganglion in its character
than someone like Heinrich.
I think that's valuable.
I think I've learned a great
deal about Marx's texts
from those guys, but it always seems to me
to be a fundamentally fighting,
still fighting off the Ricardians.
The Ricardian Marxists, still
doing that sort of thing.
And that's all great, and
I'm totally on their side
on that fight, but I don't think
it has an immediate
relationship to anything
like the political payoff
or the political intervention of capital.
And so I'm not really sure.
And you can see that in the bracketing
of the historical material when they try
to reconstruct "Capital"
along those lines, I think.
- Okay, Paul's system
is apparently crashed.
So I'm jumping into moderate
for a bit while he reboots.
It seems as though there's
really a lot of interest
in this understandably and
this interest about Marx
and ideology and what sort of critique
is being developed in "Capital".
And so let's continue to
discuss that for a bit.
There are a number of questions on it,
Patrick Coppola would you
like to read your question?
Can we unmute Patrick?
Please?
- [Patrick] Yeah, I
think this isn't really
a question either.
I think just from the way
that I'm approaching Marx
and like being open to
the way that other people
approach Marx, I'm unclear
on what you're trying to say
about how critique functions in Marx
because of what I think that means.
I agree that if, like I
understand what you were saying
by like a political critique of Science,
it's probably better characterized
than that by I forget what
you can try say that again
like the producing enlightenment
and then shedding off ideology,
but I've always linked
critique to like this,
like thing that happens beginning with con
that I see.
Because I'm approaching Marx
more from like a philosophical
background where like the
like appropriate dualidic
gets like centered in
philosophical method.
So, yeah and I would, I would
agree that I've really paid
attention to like,
Marx's the popularization
of marches language like the
language in the Grundrisse
and contribution to political economy.
He's talking about all like
universal this, particular that
like every other category, it seems to,
the I forget if the language
is like that in "Capital".
But and alienation is
still a category used
in those texts too.
So, yeah, I don't know if
what I'm saying is clear.
- Well, I mean, you raised a few issues.
so I don't know that
I'll get to all of them
but I do think that connection
to the history of critique
and the way the different ways
in which critique gets used
to entitle different projects.
I mean, I think that's an interesting
and a storied question.
One that I wouldn't be
able to do great justice to
but I do think there's a
fairly straightforward way
in which I think the
critique of political economy
is a critique in a sense
that con could recognize,
which is that, part of what a critique,
what the critique of pure reason does,
what it does is it finds the
proper domain of pure reason
that defines it.
It finds the polices where the limits
beyond which if it goes,
it produces monsters.
So in some important sense
that's what Marx is doing as well
with the critical political economy
and that he's trying to
define political economy.
And that means to delimit
it right, to find its limits
to find the points beyond
which it cannot go.
And in that sense to relativize it,
to locate it in the sphere
of history and knowledge.
So I think that's fairly,
I think you can say that
and I don't think that's
super controversial.
Yeah, I'll stop there.
- Okay, Alex Locascio,
who is Michael Heinrich's
really excellent translator.
English translator has
a couple of questions
and let's give him a
chance to ask one of them.
They're both interesting questions
but we have a number to get through.
So Alex, please pick one of
your questions and ask it.
Can we unmute him?
- Alex I don't know how to
abolish the value for them.
I'm sorry, I assume that takes
care of the other question.
- I just went to the bathroom, sorry.
I came late.
Yeah I wanted you to expand on your point
that you've made in
previous articles about Marx
being closer to the marginal
revolution in economics
than classical political economy
in light of what Michael
said a few weeks ago
about the speculation that
if Marx had been confronted
with the marginalist
revolution, that he probably
would have had great respect,
for example for its attempts
at Mathematical formalization.
- So I think the only thing
that I've committed myself
to in print is that I think
of Marx as much closer
to the Austrians in general.
But not necessarily to
marginalism as such.
So, and by that I'm
really mean that I think,
and this comes out already in the book.
It's not gonna be a big shock to anybody
but I think that in particular
high X understanding
of a market as an information
sharing mechanism,
as a place where you learn about society
and thinking of prices as signals,
I think that that is
something that is very,
it's present in Germ, in
Marx's discussion of fetishism.
So that's the sort of thing
that I'm thinking about.
I agree with you that I think
Marx was even undertaking
some of the Mathematical
studies in order to add,
like he had encountered a
couple of the early articles
of the marginal revolution as I recall.
And he was like, it's
something that he would have
had he been healthy, I'm sure
he would have taken to study.
But I think the question of,
getting away from the Bible graphical,
like what would a confrontation
between Marx's critique
of political economy and
marginal utility theory,
what would that look like?
I think that's a very
hard question to answer.
I think obviously, Simon Clark
has taken a stab at that,
which I think is a very admirable
attempt in many regards.
But that's what I would say.
- Okay, thank you for that.
We have a question about
the Russian translation
maybe switching things up a little bit.
And the question is I'm
reading a message from Paul
saying that his chat is now blank,
he's back but his chat is blank.
So this question came from Zabel
and the question is, I'm gonna just,
unless I don't see Zabel
in the chat at this point.
So I'll just read it,
and the question is that
the the Russian translation
is important Marx thought highly of it.
And so why bring the French translation
so much into play and not give
the same kind of attention
extrapolating a little bit
to the to the Russian translation.
And Will, I know you've thought a lot
about the French translation.
I mentioned that in the introduction,
I mean the obvious answer I
suppose is that Marx basically
did much of a French translation himself.
And so, there are parts of
it that function essentially
as commentary on his work.
He also, as we know how
to somewhat low opinion
of the French intellectually,
maybe, I mean, in his exchange
with angles of well-known
exchange about the punch translation,
he recycled some old German tropes
about French culture and its
strengths and its weaknesses
and suggests there that he
thinks that they need some help
in understanding "Capital".
And so that he's going
to do some translating
that's a mix really of
translation and self commentary.
So in any case, what are
your thoughts on this?
- Now, I mean, it's a good question.
So part of this comes down to
like what's your sense of Marx
as a person and how do
you read his letters?
For example, some of these letters,
I certainly Marx was thrilled
to have a Russian translation
coming out, and he was
very happy with that.
I think that some of his,
I don't talk about it
or I don't spend a lot
of work on it precisely
for the reason that you mentioned
Paul which is just that,
he had such a direct hand
in the French translation.
He did an immense amount of revising
and retranslating that.
So I think that's important to mention
and I think it makes the
French translation much more,
I mean, and at that point,
you know, Marx is, I mean, Marx
learned Russian absolutely.
But Marx had known French for decades
and had written in French
and had worked in French.
And I think his sense of what
was going on in the French
translation would have been
just as good as the sense
of what was going on in the in
the German original edition.
And I think that matters.
I think that the two German editions
and the French edition,
stand together as the the ones that Marx,
that I think we can
attribute to Marx himself.
Whereas the Russian
translation has to have
just a bit more distance
from Marx's own hand.
But that's all.
- I mean, I would say
that any good translation
is gonna help you,
there's gonna be an interesting fruitful
take on the work.
But the question is from a kind of
like philological perspective,
which do you want to use to
help clarify certain terms
or thinking in that way about
bringing the French edition
and that's long been an aim
of translators with "Capital".
And one of the things that Foulkes
has taken a lot of heat
for is not making good
on his commitment to integrating
the the French tradition
of the French edition, excuse
me, into his translation
either citing moments
where the French tradition,
the French, why do I
keep saying tradition,
when I'm in edition excuse me,
the French tradition is quite different.
And it does again, function
sort of as commentary
or just not taking it into account
when he translated the text.
And there's an interesting history.
If I may continue in
this lane for a moment.
Among Marx translators of not doing
what they say they're
going to do to an extent
it goes back to angles.
And if you read his long
epistolary statements
about what should be done
in a Marx translation
and then you look at
the edition of "Capital"
that he basically oversaw,
you see some pretty striking disparities
but I'm gonna move on
now to another question
on gaining rapidly, greater
and greater appreciation
for Paul North, whom I
already appreciated immensely.
Now his ability to do
this moderation and apply.
So Philip Wohlstetter, I don't
know, it's a German name,
if you pronounce it with
a German pronunciation
or if it's Wohlstetter,
Wohlstetter, in any case,
Phillip would you like
to read your question?
Can we unmute Phillip, please?
- Sure, you couldn't pronounce
it either way if you like.
The question really is
people have taken both
quote economics or true economics
and a critique of political economy
which is the critique of the
categories bourgeois economy.
And I'm wondering how one can avoid
Mexican (mumbles) together.
I know when Will is
talking about Marx as close
to the Austrians and so forth.
I'm sort of trying to think, it's obvious
that there are different levels in the tax
particularly between one in volume three
and all the attempts at
Mathematics at the time.
But it leads to a larger
question of how does one sink.
The critique of political
economy and the categories
which is utterly valid still
and tells us more about the roots
of how capitalism operates
than any other social
theory of capitalism.
And what can be salvageable
from a discipline
that's called economics at the moment.
So I dunno if that's coherent at all
but that would be my question.
- I think one of the big questions,
and this is sort of,
I mean it was raised by Alex's
question about marginalism
but it goes beyond that as well.
But I think there is a real
question about whether,
to what extent would a
critique of economics,
a critique of contemporary economics,
if Marx like project were
to get off the ground today,
what would it have to look like?
There's a long tradition
of Marxists trying to sort
of shoehorn later
developments in economics
into Marxist critique to
basically find ways of,
building a little shanty off the side
and putting any new economics in there.
And I think it's always a valid question
to ask what you is that actually
a legitimate procedure anymore?
I mean, I think like one of
the dangers of Marx's procedure
is that the political critique
of Science can be done well,
and that can be done badly.
And certainly I think that
there are plenty of people
on both on the left and in particular,
from a Marxist background
who are too dismissive
of contemporary Social Science work,
like in the name of
historical concreteness
or in the name of following the movement
or things like that.
I think it's always a live
question and a legitimate one
to ask, do we have a
critique of contemporary
Social Sciences that matches
the critique of political economy?
And it's not obvious to me that we do.
- All right, I'm gonna let
you continue to ask questions
'cause having got kicked out
my chat got totally evacuated,
but there was a question that
got reposted that was earlier
and I missed.
So maybe we could just ask open up the mic
of Scott Ritner to not skip him again.
Can we open Scott's mic?
Scott, are you there?
- I am here.
- Thank you.
- Thanks Will so much for your talk.
I was wondering, you mentioned
right at the end of your talk
a comment about--
- I'm sorry, Scott.
I hate to say this but I've
been interrupted on my end
for just one second.
Can I just take a pause.
- Sure.
- Can you take that back (indistinct).
- I love this.
It really is the thing that we all hide
when we go into the institution is the,
all of the thing that goes beyond,
behind all of our work, all
of that family obligation.
- Exactly, that's right.
- Here we get to see it.
- (mumbles) Intellectual production.
(Indistinct)
- Okay Scott, where were you?
- Yeah is that the same as
outgoing seven year old?
- It's the very famous seven
year old, that's right.
- Thanks, you mentioned
just at the very end
of your talk and it was almost
kind of a throw away comment,
but I have to ask about it.
That you find no basis
for pessimism in capital
but I want to challenge
you on that a little bit.
To ask if Marx's analysis
especially in his more historical
chapters is correct, wouldn't it require
sort of concerted pessimistic
action to affect change
in the world
rather than optimistic,
philosophical interpretation?
- Some mystic action.
I guess, yeah, I'm not sure.
I'm not sure.
I'll just try to clarify
what I meant by pessimism.
And then you can tell me
whether or not that like runs up
against what you were trying to say,
which is so I guess it's no surprise to me
that 20th century critical theorists
would be extremely pessimistic.
They would be pessimistic on the basis
of real historical experience.
They would be pessimistic on the basis,
not only of the failure of
the revolution in Germany,
not only on the basis of
the experience of Nazi-ism
and fascism, not only on the experience
of the failures of the dreams
of what the Soviet
revolution would deliver.
There are many, many, many
reasons to be pessimistic
in 1930, in 1940, in 1950, in 1960.
So it's no surprise that
folks would be pessimistic.
I think it's an interesting
question to ask whether,
I mean, I guess it's
an interesting question
to ask whether that pessimism,
that justifiable pessimism,
that reasonable pessimism is
then a retro active criticism
of Marx for his lack of
pessimism, or whether is in part
a result of the expectations
of revolution changing
between 1870 ish and 1930 ish.
And my suspicion is that
to some extent, it's both,
I think that the experience
already of the commune
aught to and indeed it
gave lots of people,
good basis for, much more
pessimistic accounts of
what the possibilities for
working class revolution were
in Europe and how quickly
things were going to go
as well as and that doesn't
even take into account,
experiences in Britain and so forth.
So I guess there's just a
huge field of exploration
and questioning there.
I don't think that political
action is necessarily allied
with pessimism nor do I think
that theory is necessarily
allied with optimism.
So I guess that's part of
the reason for my hesitation
about the question.
- Yeah, thanks, I think that
you and I are on the same page
at least in the first part of your answer
I didn't mean to imply that
theory is aligned with optimism.
Some of the fact that
I mentioned that Adorno
had entered the room but in any case,
I think that we largely agree upon that.
I guess my question more was about,
thinking about like the idea
within perhaps the section
on so-called primitive accumulation.
The continuation of primitive accumulation
or so-called primitive accumulation,
even after the sort of taking hold
of "Capital" as an international
system of totality, et cetera.
And the sort of struggles against that,
which may or may not turn out
the way we desire them to,
I think is more along the
lines of what I was thinking
in terms of pessimism.
But I think you and I are more or less
on the same page, thank you.
- Well, I'll read it for him.
What are important differences
between Marx's thought
and that of republicanism even
in its most radical forms?
I'm pushing you intentionally
to show us what is at stake
if we don't go in the
Republican direction.
Good to see you Will.
So I guess, you know the owner maybe.
- They from online, the unreal world.
So it's a good question.
I mean, I think the line of demarcation,
I guess there were two
lines of demarcation
that I would draw between Marx
and the Republican
tradition broadly construed.
The first I think, is Marx's
understanding of fetishism.
I just think, I think his understanding
of the impersonal domination
of the market is something
that is a complete conceptual innovation
within the field of Republican theory.
And it really does
scramble some of the terms
of republicanism because
republicanism historically
and contemporarily is
worried about the Lord
that you can see.
Not about the one you can't.
And so the institutions of
republicanism are all built
around the idea of protecting people
from personal domination.
And that means personal
dependency to some extent.
And that is the other side.
The other side is that without
that analysis of the market
as dominating, it's really
hard to universalize
republicanism as a theory
of equal Liberty for all.
Because the Liberty that was traditionally
conceived of by Republicans
as non domination,
as freedom from the
arbitrary will have another
really hinged on having a
place to go to be independent.
Having a private sphere to
retreat into that would give you
an independent basis in the world.
And so you get something
like this in a rent.
You get an attempt to update republicanism
for the contemporary world
and what that really amounts
to is a denigration and refusal of society
and a real failure to
grapple with the market.
So I think when you bring the market in
and you try to understand
the market as itself,
a form of domination,
it really causes havoc
for a lot of the other
categories of other Republicans.
I mean, I think that means
that the political institutions
of Marxian communism, they
clearly have Republican
inspiration and that's true,
you get it in Lennon too,
whatever it just rolls on down, right?
Like you get, arming the
people and large deliberative
assemblies and recall of legislators.
Like these are pretty classic things,
but I think it is true
that that is in some sense,
a failure of Marx's to
really grapple with how much
the theoretical innovation
and what sort of impacts
that would have on the need
for new political institutions.
And I think that's just
an unsolved problem
in the history of Marxism.
- Okay, we're gonna wind things down now.
And so here is one of the final questions.
This question is this buzz
about this question in the chat
This is from Rafael Khachaturian, sorry.
No, I missed that one badly
but Rafael would you like to
read your question please?
- Yeah, absolutely, Will
first of all thank you
for taking the time to join us
in this great conversation.
I wanted to post this
question of coming back
to what you mentioned about the idea
of critical Social Science.
Or critical Social Science
as an emancipatory project.
And to what extent is that
related to the critique
of the state that Marx
intended to make a volume
of "Capital" or dedicate
volume of "Capital" to
but never got around to doing it?
And I think in a sense that
so much of the later history
of Marx's theory and
practice can be understood
as a way of trying to fill in those gaps
or those lacunae of what Marx left unsaid
about political power
and how to approach it.
That I think, what does
this omission itself,
tell us about the relationship
between state power and political economy?
- That's a great question, Raphael.
So, I mean, first to Marx's intentions,
I mean Marx intended this,
Marx intended that, Marx
intended everything.
Like he made plans for every eventuality.
And I think a lot of his
plans were pretty cheap.
They were like, oh, I'm
really interested in this.
I'm gonna write it down as
something I want to tackle
at some point or another.
I mean, my own sense from having,
try to work through all of
this is that the closest
to that Marx actually gets is the section
on primitive accumulation
at the end of "Capital".
And that attempt to
think through the state,
as what I call the violent and
armed servant of "Capital",
I think there's a lot of
potential in that conception
of the state as dependent
on "Capital" accumulation
and as you know, attempting
to create the conditions
for "Capital" accumulation.
I think that has promise.
But it's just a hint of the
work that would need to be done
and trying to bring, the sort
of traditional conception
of the state as armed bands of men.
Trying to bring the
treatment of the repressive
straight apparatuses into a
discussion of the reliance
of the state on debt
financing and the reliance
of the states on tax financing
and the rough interactions
between the armed apparatuses
of the state and the financial dependence
of the state on capital accumulation.
All that is,
I mean it's just a blank
spot for an immense amount
of work to be done.
That Marx certainly did not do for us.
- This does seem like a
good moment to pause, Paul.
So we're are gonna thank Professor Roberts
for his talk and his
immensely generous gift
of his time and intelligence
and conversation.
So thank you again, a
moment of great applause.
You can't hear it, but it's going on.
You can see it.
We thank you.
We're trying to think through this book
and you really pushed us hard.
So thank you so much.
I don't know--
- Thank you all for coming.
- I don't usually give
a plug for the next talk
but it happens to be tomorrow.
So we have our double header this week.
If you wanna hear Karen
on question of human being
in Marx you can tune back
in tomorrow night at six.
We also have a talk next
week, I believe as well.
So we're piling these on,
thank you all for attending
and we'll let you go now
until the next time, thanks.